[Music]
part two of my interview with the First
Lady Melania Trump tomorrow she traveled
to two military bases and we took the
interview at the USS George HW Bush
aircraft carrier - she wanted to thank
the troops for their service they'll be
separated many of them this holiday
season separated from their loved ones
here's some incredible behind-the-scenes
footage many of you have recently
returned home from deployment I'm
honored to be able to say welcome home
and thank you for answering the call of
duty we know that we are free because
you are brave and I speak on behalf of
my husband when I tell you we are
forever grateful for your service the
President and I thank you for all that
you do
after we leave here we will be flying to
the USS George HW Bush aircraft carrier
to visit with the crew onboard that stop
will not only allow me to visit with
more members of our military but it
would be very meaningful after the
recent passing of President Bush I want
to let you all know that the President
and I are so grateful and have
unconditional appreciation for all that
you do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone I'm very honored to be
here with you today thank you so much
for your service and your sacrifice
thank you all for keeping us all safe
and free the president and I we are very
proud of you and we wish you a Merry
Christmas and a happy and healthy New
Year
god bless you god bless your families
may God bless the United States